foreign
it is a great pleasure and even greater
honor to have you with us at Stanford
GSB well thank you for having me wow
it's a big room here I'm pleased to say
that you are seated in front of hundreds
of globetrotting MBA students whoa many
if not most of whom are your most loyal
customers that I can assure you so thank
you well thank you I gotta I gotta hope
I hope you do well as I was gathering
materials for this interview Brian I
found myself transfixed by a certain
photo in your high school yearbook oh
what captivated
what captivated my attention was not the
photo itself which was perfectly fine
but rather the caption underneath the
photo yes why don't we take a look on
the big screen
I didn't know there would be visuals
today this is going to be oh God
already
[Applause]
Brian the good news is
as of the close of yesterday's trading
session your prediction turned off to be
turned out to be slightly Off the Mark
yes by 8.4 billion dollars to the
exercise
my uh
my dad was not very happy about that
I remember I I got home one day and he's
sitting in the dining room with that
opened and it just I don't I
if you had told me when I was in high
school
that I would be here talking to all of
you I just thought it would it was it's
kind of boggles my mind you know to be
here right now so
the founding story of your company Brian
will be familiar to many in the audience
but as a quick refresher could you walk
us through the origin of Airbnb yeah
I'll do that I'll do the quick version
but so so I'm from upstate New York
um my um my parents are both social
workers and I remember my mom telling me
one day I think I was like in high
school and she said you know I chose a
job for the love and I didn't really get
paid any money so you should make sure
that you get a job that pays you a lot
of money
and so then one day I was really
interested in art and design and then
like like I asked Santa for poorly
designed toys so I could redesign them
like really peculiar things like that
and then one day I tell my mom I said
I'm gonna be an artist and she said oh
my God you chose the only job in America
that'll pay less than a social worker
you're going to get paid nothing and
that was probably the pretext to that
yearbook quote and I said no Mom I
promise I'm gonna get a job and she said
a real job I said what's a real job she
said a real job's a job that gives you
health insurance so you don't have to
live in my basement so that was the
context and I said all right I'll
promise you I'll get a real job with
health insurance I get to RISD thinking
I want to be an artist and then I I felt
like the moment I got on campus I was
born like 100 years too late for what I
wanted to do because you know like I was
like an artist I was a painter a drawer
and photography had replaced a lot of
the need in society to do a lot of
things I want to do and I didn't know
what to do at RISD and all of a sudden
you have to pick a major and I was a
freshman and there was a department head
and he said there's this field called
industrial design it's a design of
everything from a spaceship to a
toothbrush and everything in between and
I thought to myself okay that's what I'm
going to do
so I got into industrial design I
graduate RISD I'm now I moved to
California I wanted to come to
California I was like I didn't really
know the difference in Lan SF very much
never been to California so my friend
was willing to come to La so I got my
friend to come to LA with me I get a job
as an industrial designer at a design
firm I'm like designing products for
um for like entrepreneurs and I even
um I like the firm I was at was like
they had like really small budgets so I
would do like products like all the
different times and so people bring me
ideas and we think about what's the
market strategy
um you know how how are we going to
design this product how do we
manufacture it where do you distribute
it and because we were so small budget I
got to actually do the entire thing now
it's 2006. one day I my boss comes to me
and he says you're going to be on a
reality TV show and I said what and
there was a precursor to a Shark Tank
the show called American inventor and it
was like a spin-off of American Idol and
there were these contestants and they
would get fifty thousand dollars and
they have to hire a design firm and I
was the firm that one of them hired and
so all of a sudden before I knew it I
was designing a toilet seat for a
magician and that's kind of and now at
that moment it was it was a cool project
but I realized that myself what's the
difference between me and this magician
and I thought to myself the difference
is they made the chance to be an
entrepreneur I didn't and I was
designing other people's products so my
life is like I'm in a car and the road
in front of me looks exactly like the
road behind me and all of a sudden I get
a package in the mail it's they're see
it's a it's a package and it's a seat
cushion but it looks in the shape of a
human buttocks with a handle and it's
it's a product called buns and it's
from like friend from RISD and he says I
started this company we're manufacturing
this product now by the way the
product's beautiful ended up getting
sold in the Museum of Modern Art gift
shop so it's a really nice product
and he and he said come to San Francisco
and this was like my called adventure
and you know like there might be a few
times in your life where you make a
decision
and everything
about your life changes after that
decision and that's what happened I pack
everything in the backseat all Honda
Civic I have a thousand dollars bank I
get to San Francisco and then Joe tells
me the rent is one thousand one hundred
fifty dollars and I thought wow I should
have asked that before I came up to San
Francisco
but it turns out that weekend an
international design conference was
coming to San Francisco all the hotels
are sold out and we had this idea we
said well what if we just turned our
house into a bed and breakfast for a
design conference unfortunately I didn't
have any beds but Joe had three air beds
we pulled them out of the closet and we
call the airbed and breakfast.com and at
that point my mom said so I guess you
don't have that job of health insurance
anymore and I said no Mom I'm an
entrepreneur and she said no you're
unemployed and that's when I realized
when you're starting it's mostly in your
head
wonderful
back then the idea of renting out your
bedroom to strangers sounded completely
foreign and even visible to Silicon
Valley investors in 2008 you sought to
raise a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for your budding Enterprise yeah
you approached more than a dozen
investors all of whom sadly turned you
down yeah in fact I have here a couple
of those rejection emails investors sent
to you these exhibits are great
and it's slightly embarrassing but would
you be so kind as to read one of them
out for our edification yes
thank you you want me to read them yes
okay so we'll read this one uh oh I know
this person okay
hi Brian apologize for the delayed
response
we've had a chance to discuss internally
and unfortunately don't think this is
the right opportunity for blank from an
investment perspective this is my
favorite part the potential Market
opportunity did not seem large enough
for our required model now it's travel
about the same size as oil
but it wasn't large enough
but you can imagine like they didn't see
it travel they saw strangers sleeping in
other people's homes like I'll give you
an example
the first investor Joe and I ever met
was in university Cafe this Cafe an
investor walks in he goes to the get a
smoothie he sits down he never picks his
head up he's drinking a smoothie he's
like on a straw picking up a smoothie
we're pitching him halfway through the
presentation he gets up
because he has to like move his car
we still haven't seen him since so that
was our first pitch we pitched Paul
Graham at y combinator we end up getting
a y Commander the first question Paul
Graham asked me is people are actually
doing this
like staying each other's homes and I
said yes so the second question was well
what's wrong with them the interview
kind of went downhill from there but
over the course of this journey you know
we um we're about to leave our
interviews and
Joe takes out a box of cereal
and a box of cereal we design so we'll
take a quick detour we provided housing
in 2008 for the Republican and
Democratic national conventions and you
remember that was when Barack Obama was
running for president it was like a huge
movement and that weekend we launched
and we got like 80 bookings and I
thought at this point we've made it
we're huge like a bunch of blogs covered
us I'm like we're like the Beatles of
tech right now and then all of a sudden
the next weekend for uh for Senator
McCain we got two bookings and then the
week after we got no bookings and I
realized if only there were political
conventions every week we'd have a
business so we recall the air bed and
breakfast the air beds weren't selling
so we said I know what you're thinking
why not breakfast
and so we created this Barack Obama and
John McCain theme breakfast cereal we
call the Breakfast the Obama oh cereal
Obama owes like little Cheerios the
breakfast of change and we learned about
John McCain and he was a captain in the
Navy and I thought oh my God captain
Captain McCain's a Maverick in every
bite so we made these boxes and at this
point my mom's like yeah you're
definitely unemployed like this is just
not a good sign
um and I and so
we end up designing these boxes we call
General Mills like hey can you make a
hundred thousand of these they're like
please don't ever call us again
um if you do we'll call security so we
ended up I'm making that up I can't
remember who it was but some big cereal
company so we end up getting like a
thousand box cereal we hand goulded them
ourselves like I remember handling
cereal boxes these collectible breakfast
cereal thinking I wonder if Mark
Zuckerberg ever glued cereal boxes and
the answer was no he didn't this is not
a good sign but we ended up making like
thirty thousand dollars of collectible
breakfast cereal so we basically said at
that point we're cereal entrepreneurs
and that was how we funded the company
so we are in this interview Paul Graham
he's like what's wrong with you like
these people why are strangers staying
together and we by when we leave the
interview we give them these boxes of
cereal and he said what are these and we
said we made these he goes why did you
make these he said actually this is how
he funded the company because no other
investors give us money and he said well
if you can figure out how to get people
to pay forty dollars for a four dollar
lots of cereal maybe just maybe you can
figure out how to get strangers to live
with each other so that's when we
entered Y combinator in 2009 after you
know a couple dozen investors just
thought this was not for them
so now that you get your cash infusion
from selling breakfast here yeah you've
pivoted back from breakfast to beds yeah
we realized the market size for housing
was probably better than breakfast and
one of the keys to airbnb's initial
success was its emphasis on accuracy
over speed to Market yes instead of
targeting millions of potential
customers at once you focused on
converting 100 people at a time what
gave you that discipline
okay so it's the first day of Y
combinator it's January 2009. by the way
I want to set the stage for you do you
remember what was going on in January
2009 like like like economic crisis the
Great Recession the economy was so bad
and why come here has thing called demo
day so the end of three months all these
investors come Paul Graham sends us an
email before why common air starts he
says
the economy is so bad we don't know if
any investors will show up for demo day
so if you want to defer you can defer
that's how bad it was and so we said no
we're going to do this so we get to Y
combinator it's the first a and I get
the
worst piece of advice I ever got and the
best piece of advice I ever got the
worst piece I've ever got was Paul
Graham you have to move to Mountain View
we never did I'm like you don't need to
move a Mountain View you can be anywhere
um although it's cool in Mountain View
um
but then I got the best piece of advice
I ever got he goes to the Whiteboard and
he draws like it's all hard to visualize
but he draws like imagine if you were to
take a section
plan of the Washington mall that like
that long like it's just like a little
stream of water and then he does another
section of what would look like a well
and he said these are the same volumes
but he said it's better to have a
hundred people that deeply love you if
this axis is number of people and this
acts as love focus on 100 people that
love you rather than getting a million
people that kind of like you
and I think this is a profound piece of
advice it may have been the best piece
of advice ever gotten and it actually
runs counter-intuitive to almost
everything that everyone says everyone
focuses on scale but scale requires
people to have a deep passion because if
you focus on 100 people love you there's
two things that happen the first thing
is how do you know how to make something
for a million people I don't know where
to start but if I pick one person in the
audience and I study you and I take your
journey and say how do we like improve
this part of the journey how do we prove
that part of the journey you can
actually do something really personal
and if you design something keep
iterating until they love it and don't
stop improving until that one person
loves it and you're not allowed to get
the second person to the first person
loves it and then you get the second
person and you keep editing until they
love it and then the third person and
what ends up happening is two things one
you design this perfect experience which
is a different part of your mind than
the industrial part of your the your
your your mind that has to figure out
how to scale this and the second thing
is when people love your service they
become your marketing department they
tell other people so the first day why
come here they give you this t-shirt and
on the T-shirt it says make something
people want and we thought what if we
went even further make something people
love and so we've now done these
exercises we had this process I named
after the movie Snow White I learned
that Walt Disney in 1937 created Snow
White it was one of the first used of
the storyboard because was like this
really long feature link animated movie
and he storyboarded the experience and I
thought to myself what if we storyboard
the perfect experience for the Airbnb we
actually hired Pixar storyboard artists
to do this and then we what we like to
do is like pick one frame of the
experience so the moment of truth in
Airbnb is when you check in right you're
like is this going to be what I think it
is and there's a really bad version of
check-in like the host didn't show up
and there's kind of a good version of a
check-in they showed up
but we wanted to think to ourselves what
would make the experience something
people love and so we created this
exercise we thought like you know when
you go on Airbnb that's also true Uber
like a five-star mostly means like
nothing bad happened
and we thought
well what if there was like a six star
what would that be when you check into
Airbnb
and the six star is you get to your
Airbnb and you know there's like a
bottle of wine waiting on a table and
there's like some fruit and they like
have a handwritten note to you and like
okay that's like really nice and then I
thought well what would a seven star
experience be a seven star experience is
they get a limo they pick you up the
airport and there's this like whole
curated experience you get to the you
get to the house and they know you like
surfing and there's a surfboard they are
waiting for you and all that stuff
so then I thought what would an eight
star experience be like
an eight star experience you get to the
airport
there's a giant elephant
and you get on the elephant and there's
a parade in your honor and you go to
your Airbnb
so what would a Nine Star experience be
The Nine Star experience is the Beatles
check-in
you land and there's five thousand
teenagers cheering your name and you get
your Airbnb you have to do a press
conference in the front lawn
so what's a 10 star experience keep
going a 10 star experience you show up
and Elon Musk says we're going to space
you do get back eventually and
point of this story
is that you maybe can't make an 8 9 or
10 star experience but most people try
to design something that's just good
enough but if you can add that six or
seven star if you can design something
really amazing and you use the part of
your brain the handcrafted part of your
brain to create that perfect experience
then you can reverse engineer how to
industrialize this Millions times over
and what happens is people love your
product and they tell everyone else
about your product and what ended up
happening in our business is Hilton was
started in 1919 over a hundred years ago
and we were able to have the entire
growth of Hilton in 10 years and this is
how you do it without you know we had
some marketing but not you know
initially not a lot as you said Word of
Mouth marketing really helped Airbnb get
off the ground in major cities around
the world
yet one corollary of your newfound
success is that government regulators
and the powerful hotel lobby were now
breathing down your neck how did you
deal with those Regulators oh man
um
yeah I I
um there were some things that were
initially out of my depth like they did
not teach you at RISD how to work with
government Regulators
um
so I I always grew up thinking if like
people don't like you you should avoid
them that seems kind of intuitive right
um or you should fight them and like
disagree with them and they're your
opponent
and then in 2011
um I hired a uh an executive my first
executive her name is Belinda Johnson
she was our uh Chief legal officer
eventually became our CEO
and she told me something that was
counterintuitive to me she said if
people don't like you you should meet
with them
and I said really why would I do that
wouldn't it go horribly wrong and she
said no because it's hard for people to
hate you up close
and I think that's a really important
lesson
you know so I said okay well who doesn't
like me and it turned out a lot of
people and so instead of me having a
tour where I went on tour to meet
everyone like me I told our team
um I want to meet everyone who doesn't
like me and it turned out they kept me
busy for a long time and um but I would
meet with these government officials and
sometimes the meetings would start a
little a little they were a little
hostile at first but I had a rule that I
would always listen first and seek to
understand them and I think you know my
dad used to say like 90 of life is just
showing up it's actually not true in
Tech but when it comes to showing
respect 90 of life sometimes is showing
someone respect and listening to them
and if you just get in the mindset of
listening to people then through
creativity you can decide you can
realize a win-win and I realize they you
know like I would hear from them we tell
the story and then through that I had
this image that we create this model
City and we'd roll out the regulation
everywhere and I did it in one city and
I get to the next city and they're we're
like yeah uh but we're different you
know we're not Portland we're not San
Francisco we're not Los Angeles
and so then I realized we had to treat
every city personally so we actually
started meeting with like hundreds of
cities we have now 90 of the top 200
markets have a regulation in place we've
uh collected six billion dollars of
Transit oxy tax since we started and I I
I think maybe the final lesson I'll just
say to this is
somebody asked me um
what is the biggest thing you've learned
or the biggest surprise
that you've learned starting Airbnb
and I'll tell you what it is and this is
proven from firsthand experience and
from data you know everything's been
used more than a billion and a half
times it was like the worst idea that
ever worked it wasn't supposed to work
in fact the first time I told somebody
the idea he said Brian I said yes he
said I hope that's not the only idea
you're working on
but a billion a half times later what
I've realized is the thing that
surprised me is not how different people
are it's actually how similar people are
and I think we live under this illusion
that we're so different than everyone
else and I think we tend to focus on the
one percent that makes us all different
and that's really good there's really
positive parts of preserving our culture
and understanding our diversity but when
you start to think the other is so other
from you that gets very very pernicious
and having met with you know people all
over the world I realized that people
with strongest opinions about other
people are the ones without passports
and the people the strongest opinions
about business people or government or
people have never worked in those
businesses and so if we can build
Bridges meet people bring people
together we will realize the other is
not so other there were 99 the same and
actually through creativity you can
actually find win-wins through everyone
so that's probably what I learned from
that lesson
at the same time that Regulators were
encircling you you had to navigate
internal growing pains in short order
you found yourself at the helm of a
multinational company with many hundreds
of employees around the world as you
mentioned earlier you are a designer by
trade not an engineer
how did you leverage your background as
a designer to inspire loyalty and
followership among your employees whoa
wow loyalty and followership I like that
um
well so let's go back to RISD when I got
to risty I'm 41 so I I was there in the
early 2000s
there was this huge obsession with the
idea of Designing design kind of like
having a seat at the table you know
there's this kind of thing that like
artists and designers are usually not in
positions of power I mean you take the
Fortune 500 how many CEOs The Fortune
500 companies went to design school
I don't know if there are any very few
so how many board members there's
probably an average of like maybe 12
members or 10 to 12 members per board so
maybe approximately 600 board members in
this Fortune 500 how many of them are
creative people or designers not many
okay let's go down the list how many
executive teams do you have designers or
creative people on the executive team
and even today not very many
and so at RISD there was this whole
movement well how can we get designed in
the boardroom and Joe and I had this
kind of audacious almost arrogant
thought why would design be in the
boardroom why wouldn't design run the
boardroom why don't we start a company
and I think I'll just stop by saying to
me design I think a lot of people think
of design is how something looks
and to me design is a much deeper idea
design is how something fundamentally
works you know I think design makes the
complex simple and it focuses on every
single detail design is really about
understanding the essence I think what
Steve Jobs has said design is a
fundamental soul of a man-made creation
that reveals itself through subsequent
layers and so I think that design it's
not just how something looks it's how a
way to think about the world and a way
to simplify and Engineers I think tend
to want to narrow in reduce my
co-founder Nate likes to narrow in and
and get very focused on a problem you
can contain because you got to build it
and designers we tend to want to zoom
out to the frustration engineers and be
very very holistic but I do think that
that holistic thinking
affected everything I think it changed
how we ran the company you know I can
talk in a second about how we run the
company it's really different than most
of the tech companies it you know it is
do you have to tell a story constantly
so we learned how to be really good
storytellers a lot of of people build
products and understand stories it
helped understand how we design our
products how we make our products so it
was really kind of everything and it's
weird it's almost like I'm an anomaly
that I'm even here like the fact that I
went to a design school and I ran a
giant tech company it is a kind of a
weird anomaly and if you imagine like
a human body there's The Head and the
Heart and if you were to cut off the
body at the head and take the head and
you cut it off at the left side or
whatever that's kind of the the world of
business we don't usually use our full
Minds to like run companies and I think
we tend to get very myopically focused
near term on that which is extremely
measurable you know not everything that
counts can be counted not everything
that that can be counted counts and so
that was a quote by Linus Pauling a
Nobel prize-winning
scientist and so I think I think that's
kind of how I think about design is just
really trying to understand the essence
of something and really distill it down
Brian let's fast forward to the pandemic
yeah Airbnb lost 80 percent of its
Revenue over eight weeks in March and
April of 2020. you had to lay off nearly
a quarter of your Workforce that's
nearly 2 000 employees what lessons in
crisis management can you impart to us
oh geez um
well let me just let me start by saying
this
um for many years I would tell this
founding story of Airbnb I've literally
told it now like thousands of times
and I remember saying to myself
um I'll probably never have a crazier
chapter in my life than starting Airbnb
and little did I know about a pandemic
that was about to come that would turn
our entire world upside down but let me
actually go to a few minutes before the
few few months before the pandemic
so Airbnb we started we go on a rocket
ship it's amazing and it's late 2019
and we're preparing to go public
and
I go on a hike in Bolinas California
it's like a couple hours north of here
and I go on a hike with my co-founder is
Joe Nate
and we're reflecting on this amazing
company bill it was like at the time
valued at 30 billion dollars
and we're feeling really proud of
ourselves but something is gnawing at us
and the thing gnawing at us is it's
maybe it's like Airbnb was an adolescent
and it was about as awkward as my actual
adolescence you saw that photo and um
you know we kind of like looked like a
human like an adult but we like we had
the body of adult we were like kind of
still kids
and
it was like I realized that like the
company was like we were like growth was
slowing costs were Rising we had 10
divisions at Airbnb so like a homes
division experiences we had a
transportation a magazine and then each
division had subdivisions we had
basically like 10 marketing departments
we were building software the way most
tech companies do which is you try to uh
you know kind of decentralize as much as
possible allow people to move quickly
every person is like a cell in a body
you have an individual task be of the
information the entire company we
democratize data and you do a lot of
experimentation in a b tests to figure
out like what you want to do we're
spending a lot of money in Performance
Marketing and the aggregate of this I
felt like we had lost that magical like
10 star experience it was starting to
become like another company there was a
bit of bureaucracy it was difficult to
get work done and I just I didn't know
what to do and I remember telling Joe
and Nate I feel like I had a dream that
I left the company and I just came back
and they said would you find I said I
was kind of horrified because this is
not quite the company we set out to
build but we had an IPO coming up and
they're like what do you do and I said I
don't know I mean we have an IPO we're
not going to rebuild the company
so we're going into the new year and I'm
like thinking we need to make some
changes I don't know what we're going to
do
and all of a sudden the pandemic hits
and our business drops by 80 percent in
eight weeks
and we were doing tens of billions of
dollars and when you're our size
in the business drops by 80 percent in
eight weeks that is like being an
18-wheeler going 80 miles an hour
and then you slam on the brakes
nothing good happens
and this was like
you know I um
I've never had you know
within weeks
journalists were predicting
is this the end of Airbnb
this is weeks after we are preparing for
what's supposed to be like one of the
hottest IPOs in years
and it was completely bewildering
and I
I you know I've been I'm lucky
that I've never had like in your death's
experience but what it's been described
to me is like your life flashes before
your eyes and I think we felt like we
had at least felt like at the time a
year to have business experience and at
that moment we realized not everything
mattered and it was like if you have to
go into house and your house is burning
and you can only take half the thing in
your house what would you take
and that was the exercise we had to do
and you can learn a lot about people in
a crisis
and the person that I think you
sometimes learn the most about in crisis
is yourself
and the hardest thing
to do in a crisis is a few things you
need a crisis but the hardest thing to
manage the Christ you know what the
hardest thing the management crisis is
what I found
the hardest thing to manage the crisis
is your own psychology
because people look in your eyes and
they and if you think you're screwed
they see your eyes and they say well you
have the most information
and so you need to be optimistic but it
can't be optimism that's like delusional
has to be rooted in some some truth some
reality that people still want us to
exist and this is why
and so that optimistic mentality is the
mentality you need to be creative and
you need to be creative because in a
crisis you often have no good Solutions
so the first thing is you need to be
optimistic the second thing in a crisis
that I found is that you need to be
decisive and I think this is a struggle
for a lot of data driven people because
there's not a lot of data in the crisis
all the data is out the window and what
do you do when there's no data you have
to lean on something you need to have
courage but what does courage lean on
Courage has to lean on principles in
other words in a crisis I don't think
you make business decisions as much as
you make principal decisions and a
principal decision is like if I can't
predict the outcome how do I want to be
remembered and I think if you think of
yourself as this is our defining moment
how do we want to be remembered that is
the mentality that you need to navigate
out of the crisis and so we use those
principles and we basically a thousand
of us got into a foxhole and rebuilt the
company from the ground up we had to
reduce the size of our company and do a
layoff that was the hardest thing
probably I ever had to do
you know we reduce the payoffs of all
the executives we had we're spending
nearly a billion dollars on marketing we
took it to zero I became our marketing
department I started just doing press
interviews I did 100 interviews that
year and we just really got focused and
we actually changed how we ran the
company and I'll just say for a second
now we now run the company
so most large companies are divisional
right so you have like uh like whatever
like if you're a company you may have
like a bottle Division and you have like
a snack division so you're like a
divisional structure
we got back to being a functional
organization so we have a Design Group a
Marketing Group a finance group an
operations group
we basically reduced all the things
we're working on the company to just a
few things
and then I decided that I wanted only
leaders that were going to be in the
details I didn't want anyone that was
just a manager of people it was like if
you're um like a general in the Cavalry
you have to actually know how to ride a
horse and so you had to actually have
your hands dirty and so we had a team of
experts and we all huddled together and
we basically said we're not going to do
just this agile continuous shipping of
features every single hour of every
single day and I'll give you a sense of
what I think is wrong with software
development Silicon Valley
the general premise the software develop
on the Silicon Valley is to like
democratize data and anyone can ship
anything and this initially is faster
but when you start adding thousands of
people this slows you down and I'll use
an analogy let's say we're all making a
car and one team is designing the tires
and they design this new type of tire
but now that tire has to fit on a wheel
so you have to work on the wheel team
the wheel team's like oh wow we need to
actually make the wheels bigger to work
with this tire but to do that then that
actually changes the shape of the car so
now you need to update the body of the
car but maybe that makes the car heavier
and so maybe you need a different
battery and to manufacture it from
Battery you need to actually capitalize
that but the finance team needs to like
set different expectations investors and
do you see how everything starts to tie
together so we basically had this idea
that what if we thought of the entire
company as just one continuous like one
fluid organization I don't push decision
making down we pull it in we try to pull
as many decisions into us as possible
and be in the flow almost like an
Orchestra conductor each executive
doesn't have their own swim Lanes we all
work together on a few discreet things
every project in the company every major
project we review every either every
week every two weeks every four weeks we
have these two releases a year these
releases are where all the work together
converges to make sure everyone's
coordinated we make sure that product
and marketing are in lockstep at most
companies product people are like chefs
and marketing people like waiters and if
the waiter goes in the kitchen the chef
yells at them and there's just no
collaboration and I thought well what if
product and marketing were like working
in in in in tandem with each other so it
was just like really different way of
working and I think the way to summarize
it is we took the best of software and
the best of Hardware development and we
put it into one system because the
problem with software is there's no
constraints sometimes and so things can
be a bit of a free-for-all and the
free-for-alls can slow you down
so we basically rebuilt the company for
the ground up and to give you the punch
line before the pandemic that year
before the pandemic we lost a combo 100
million dollars
there was a question of could we be one
day profitable
and fewer than three years later we have
now done 3.4 billion dollars last year
in free cash flow
nearly 40 percent of our Revenue
becomes free cash flows for every dollar
almost 40 cents becomes free cash flow
and the amazing thing about this whole
system is we never even focused I never
focus on trying to make a lot of money I
just focus on being as efficient as
possible obsessing over the experience
focusing on every single detail and
getting really really detailed and we
would immerse for hours on a certain
topic I you know we wouldn't you know we
didn't have strategy sessions we lived
with a strategy we would have like 20
conversations not one Deep dive and I
think that way of working which I think
came a little bit from my design
background really helped us create this
huge business turnaround
I've got two more questions for you
Brian before we turn it over to the
audience I've got an easy one and a
slightly tougher one okay why don't I
give you the more difficult one first if
that's great let's do it
one long-standing criticism of Airbnb is
that it might be exacerbating
unaffordability in densely populated
cities like San Francisco by diverting
housing stock that otherwise would have
been made available to long-term tenants
who reside on those cities is there any
Merit to those concerns yeah there
absolutely is marital concerns and let
me just zoom out for a second and back
up
when we started Airbnb
we started it the origin story is Joe
and I couldn't afford to pay rent in
other words Joe and I couldn't afford to
pay for a housing and in 2008 many
people turned to Airbnb 2019 during the
financial crisis to put their homes in
Airbnb
but over the time I learned a lesson you
know when I came to Silicon Valley in
2007 the word Tech may as well have been
a dictionary definition for the word
good and if you were in Tech you were
taking a step forward for Humanity and
therefore making the world a better
place and so therefore if you grow and
what you're doing is virtuous therefore
you're making things better and I think
you know 15 years later we've now
realized another truth that if you
create something really powerful a tool
or a platform and you put in the hands
of hundreds of millions of people
that they are almost always going to use
it
and there are going to be unintended
consequences
things that you didn't foresee
and the faster something grows
the more it can hit you very quickly and
I think there is a concern about how
fast technological progress is going
and so this was a huge issue airme
wasn't designed for people to remove
housing from the market so this kind of
coincided with our working with cities
and we meet with regulators and they
said we have these concerns and said
well how can we fix it a lot of them
would say well we want to know in our
city that people who are renting their
homes this is the home they live in or
the least they live there some of the
time she said okay how will we solve
that and we ended up coming up with a
registration system where they would
register they may have an available
number of nights they can rent a year
maybe at the show proof of residence we
will handle like hotel tax that will go
to bettering cities but I think again
it's all about working with cities not
believing that your product is
inherently like virtuous maybe your idea
is but always knowing there's unintended
consequences and that's we've tried to
do and I'll just say again the heart and
soul of Airbnb
still lies in the Everyday People 90 are
individuals and that's kind of mainly
where where most of our activities
for those
for those entrepreneurs and aspiring
entrepreneurs in the audience what are
some
post-covered Trends in travel that have
captured your attention
well
um
I want to can I talk about a travel
Trend and then I think a driver of the
Travel Channel I want to talk about like
two Trend Okay so
when
when the pandemic occurred people had to
shelter in place and suddenly people
were doing their jobs on a laptop and
then many people realized well I could
take my laptop anywhere
and so suddenly people were untethered
from the place they lived and so we
started noticing that airbnbs were
starting being booked for like 30 days
or longer last quarter a fifth of our
nights booked were for stays of longer
than 30 days
nearly half our business is now longer
than a week and very few people stay in
a hotel for a week or longer and so it's
actually become a fundamentally
different use case in other words people
are living on Airbnb that was a really
big Trend the other Trend that happened
was because people weren't going to
cities because many things the cities
were closed they couldn't cross borders
they couldn't you know there wasn't
really an urban travel available across
border people started going to small
towns rural communities national parks
in other words they started going from
100 cities to a hundred thousand places
all over the world
so the two pandemic Trends where people
staying longer and going everywhere
we've now seen a rebound of a lot of
people and now this goes my other my
other point so the other trend
is that a lot of people have been like
kind of stuck in the house or landlocked
for the last few years
and they want to get out and the
pandemic is ending who knows when
exactly it's over but the pandemic's
ending and I think there's a lot of
people that have pent up demand
but I'll just end with one last Trend a
trend I'm actually concerned about I
think we can maybe help a little bit
so during the pandemic
we hired
um the now Surgeon General in the United
States he's he was also certain general
for Barack Obama
um Dr Vivek Murthy
and he said something to me that and we
hired him by the way because covet had
occurred and we wanted to keep the home
safe and so we designed this like
cleaning protocol
and he said something to me I'll never
forget he said do you know what the
number one killer in America is
and I said I don't know is it heart
disease is it cancer and he said
no in a larger sense the number one
killer in America is loneliness
that there's a lot of studies that show
that people that are lonely
the pernicious health effects is it's
equivalent of smoking a pack of
cigarettes a day and people that are
chronically lonely live uh 15 years
shorter than people who aren't and I
always thought okay that's really bad
but I had this image in my mind of like
maybe elderly people being lonely
and so I started looking at the cohorts
and it turns out that the loneliest
people in America are not senior
citizens they're teenagers
that depending upon the stats you see
some somewhere like two out of three
teenagers are chronically lonely
that correlates to feelings of
hopelessness and depression
one out of three adults in America is
lonely but two out of three teenagers is
lonely
one in five teenagers
has made a suicide plan in the last year
and I I said why is this happening this
is so crazy
and I think what's happening
as I think Modern Life is making us
lonely
and I think what's happening is like you
know you know 10 15 years ago we had
these amazing magical devices where they
brought us to this world and we could
connect with everyone but social
networking which was two-way friends
became social media which was an
audience and followers and you're
performing and the thing about and it's
not that social media is causing this I
mean fewer people have families people
people go to a church or a bowling alley
there's less physical proximity now the
office is zoom the mall is Amazon the
theater is Netflix the grocery store
sends a car and and all these things are
fourth step for Humanity and I think
they're all really great inventions but
they're like ingredients
you can't you we've got to balance
um people being online and connecting
with people having meaningful physical
interaction in the real world and this
is something that I think we're not
going to solve not under some delusion
that we're going to solve this problem
but I would like for us to be able to
focus on helping because I think travel
is a great way for people to connect and
I want to move Airbnb even more towards
a platform where it's either a way to do
reunion trips or your friends because a
lot of people now their friends don't
live in the same city when you guys
graduate many of you are going to live
in different cities than your friends
and you'll never see your friends again
unless you some of you travel
and the other thing is how do people
meet each other these days and so I'm
thinking a lot about how can airbnb's
platform be used to bring people
together to make the world feel a tiny
bit smaller because we verify the
identity of more than 100 million people
on our platform and if we could bring
people together make things feel a
little bit more intimate that's
something that I think I'd be very
interested in so it's like if I'm a
designer it's almost like we're
designing how people connect together
excellent well thank you very much for
sharing with us your insights today
Brian thank you would you like to take a
few questions from the audience thank
you so much for sharing your stories
Brian my name is Florian dalos and I'm a
second year MBA student here and I would
love to understand a bit more about the
co-founder Dynamics I find it really
interesting that in Silicon Valley so
many co-founder stories end with
conflict or lawsuits but you at Airbnb
seem to be one of the companies where
co-founders have stuck together through
thick and thin so I would be curious to
understand what the secret to the
cohesion between you Joe and Nate was
oh man that's a great question
I like to think like why am I on stage
right now
and not the person I thought maybe I
would be in my high school yearbook
and the answer
you know in addition to a lot of hard
work is a lot of luck
but I don't think of my luck as that we
came up with this idea at this time
I think the luck I have is having met my
co-founders Joe and Nate
uh that was is what makes me so lucky
you're kind of like the average the
people you're surround yourself with
and I remember when I met I knew Joe
from Misty but Joe and Nate are really
special
each of them had businesses in high
school
I think that it's really important that
when you pick Partners they're people
that you can be friends with they're
people you can imagine spending more
time than your spouse because you're
going to probably spend more time your
co-founder than your partner actually
and they're people that are so good they
almost intimidate you they challenge you
but they're also complementary one time
like a decade ago we each did like some
kind of personality test I don't it
wasn't like in Enneagram it was like one
of those kinds of things and there's
like you know the personality tests are
on like a wheel right and they kind of
put you know wheel and it turned out
that when they plotted our three
personalities they formed a perfect
equilateral triangle
and it made so much sense
that it's about the sense of mutual
respect people that are so good they
almost intimidate you but they're so
complementary and there was such a deep
respect and we had a rule the rule was
that that winning an argument was never
more important than preserving the
relationship
and the reason that's important is
because if you start a company you're
gonna have to debate like a hundred
thousand things
at least ten thousand right you're
probably debating like three things a
day
and so it's like a thousand things a
year 10 years that's ten thousand things
so no one argument can be the thing it
has it has to be this larger sense that
we're a band
and I think you got to really work hard
at the relationship almost like
exercising if you don't keep exercising
you lose you get out of shape and so we
worked really really hard and one of the
things we did in 2009 is we said every
single Sunday we're going to meet no
matter how busy we get well now it's
like sometimes Sunday becomes Thursday
but we basically meet every single week
and to this day we still do those calls
and I think a lot of human connection
requires Constant Contact constant
connection a deep sense of respect a
sense that like you know I'm only here
because of them a sense of humility and
gratitude and the sense that I'm never
going to try to win
because if I win alone I'm not going
very far
hi my name is Tomo MBA Juan I was
curious to learn about the principles
you mentioned when you're talking about
covet response uh what are your current
principles have they changed a lot are
there any uh design process so to say a
redesign process when you're thinking
about principles you operate on So when
you say principles do you elaborate time
a bit more yep you mentioned in the
covet response section
um that prints everything comes kind of
comes to the principles that you're rely
on so I was wondering what are those and
how it has been formed yeah I mean I
think that like I like to come from a
sense of first principles and um
every I think every different situation
I actually like there are some Universal
principles for the company but like say
the crisis we wrote down a number of
principles the first principle we said
is act fast and that's why we said we
have to be intuitive we have to be
courageous we have to move very quickly
a lot of people it's like imagine me on
a car chase and you're like you like
pause what should I turn you're dead so
we had to act fast the second thing is
we had to preserve Cash Cash was like
oxygen the third is we said let's act
with all stakeholders and Minds we
didn't want to be villains of the crisis
and the fourth principle I said is we
want to play to win the next travel
season so even when everyone's
retrenching we were thinking about like
kind of going forward and I think that
principles are really important because
they become like your Guiding Light in
the sky and they also I remember going
to the board we had you know when the
Christ was going on we had to have
Sunday board calls because it was almost
like three months was happening every
week
and instead and I told them I'm gonna
make like a thousand decisions I can't
run every decision by you so here are
the principles I'm going to use let's
align on these principles and if I stick
to those principles we can then stick to
this
and I generally think that's just one
example but every project I do I try to
identify what are some immutable
foundational truths that you couldn't
further distill down than those things
and make sure that you communicate them
to people
my name is Roman Scott I'm a sophomore
State political science and I just want
to ask some for somebody who's aspiring
to be an entrepreneur if there was one
thing you could tell yourself when you
were growing up or one piece of advice
you could give yourself what would that
be
one piece of advice
um
I would say just start making something
you know for example I went to risty
and I took all these classes
um but it's funny enough one of the
things that probably prepared me more
for entrepreneurship than RISD is that
Joe and I both ran like student
organizations so I ran like a club
hockey team Joe ran a club a basketball
team and Joe and I had the hardest
marketing challenge in the world how do
you get art students to go to a sports
game
and we had like little budgets but the
point is like I think
I think that a lot of the intent I think
there's going to be a Temptation for
people in this uh for you all in this
audience to seek prestige because you're
at a prestigious school I think the
problem with entrepreneurship and it's
summarized my mom's story is when you're
starting out the line between being an
entrepreneur and being unemployed is
kind of in your head and so you have to
be very careful about seeking Prestige
because seeking Prestige sometimes means
you won't get your hands dirty and if
you don't get your hands dirty you don't
actually learn the underlying principles
how do you make something how do you
struggle through something how do you
describe a story how do you convince
someone else and so I think making
something it could be like a little toy
I mean not physically toy but like a
like a thing for fun and I think just
the other thing I'd say is somebody asks
like how do you start becoming an
entrepreneur I say you start you just
start you start you don't think you act
you start very few entrepreneurs make
plans
um you know I I like the business plans
like expire the like moment you do the
first thing and so instead of making
plans I would just make something and it
makes something with the resources you
have off with you and your friends
anything that process of making
something is great and by the way the
other trick I'd say is make something
for yourself solve your own problem the
first weekend Joe and I were like wait a
second let's make a little website so we
can rent our apartment and make some
extra money that did not seem like a
billion dollar idea renting through air
mattresses in an apartment and so
there's a lot of investors that say we
like to invest in big markets well
what's the market size for people
sleeping on air mattresses so the
problem is that like I wouldn't focus on
markets that focus on solving a problem
for yourself or somebody in your life it
doesn't even have to be a big problem it
could be something kind of fun and just
start making just start doing something
Brian Before I Let You Go it is a view
from the top tradition to end each
session with a number of Rapid Fire
questions may I invite you to play along
yes let's do it
when was the last time you stayed in a
hotel
um
when I had these fake glasses and fake
mustache
um I I think I stayed one I think was
like last year for like an event
and what is the most memorable Airbnb
you've stayed in
well um
I stayed in a tree house in Burlingame
California by this couple Doug and Linda
so it's a very quick story uh this is
not rapid fire so maybe I should not
tell a story well anyway I will tell a
story because now I've half started the
Tony Story So this woman named Mackenzie
her mother her mother and father were
Doug and Linda
the father builds her tree house in the
backyard she plays in treehouse growing
up then she graduates high school goes
to college and it was treehouse in the
backyard and they're like what do we do
with a tree house and one day
MacKenzie's like why don't you put on
Airbnb the house ended up paying for the
mortgage and it was this amazing
experience
and finally I learned that you your own
apartment in San Francisco is listed on
Airbnb
how much do you charge per night and
well
um
it's free but boy I do I have some
cleaning fees no just kidding um
um it's free and when you stay with me
um you know it's a pretty cool
experience because
um it's me and my co-host Sophie
Supernova who is my 18 month old Golden
Retriever and I make what I call
chesky's chips chesky's chips are an old
family recipe of chocolate chips that I
got actually off of Google but um and
then we make dinner together and then I
take them on a tour the next day to the
office where I tell them the story of
Airbnb and and I think I'll just end by
saying this um
you know I think on the surface Airbnb
is about space and it's like oh stay
with me but I think below the spaces the
thing about Airbnb when it works the
best it's really about people it's
really about connecting to one another
it's the idea that the best way to
change someone's mind about someone else
is to walk in their shoes and the best
way to walk in the shoes is literally to
be in their home
and I think that if more people could
live together then I think you know
obviously a lot of Minds would be
changed and so that's kind of what we're
trying to do perfect thank you for
making the time today thank you it's
been a great pleasure thank you
[Music]